it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope Larry looser from
the CBS television news staff and John
Oates from the Editorial Board of the
New York Times our distinguished guests
for this evening
is Oliver lafarge president of the
Association on American Indian Affairs
it may not be generally known but a new
crisis has arisen over the American
Indian pending before Congress are a
number of bills which would remove
federal protection from about sixty
million Indians in about a dozen states
now our guest tonight a prize-winning
novelist Pulitzer prize-winning novelist
has long made a study of the American
Indian so we'd like to ask mr. La Forge
just how the Indians themselves feel
about this removal of federal protection
we've heard from over 70 tribes to date
and the voice has been absolutely
unanimous we have never heard so much
resistance on the part of the Indians to
any move as is the best so-called
termination of Indian status well just
what does federal protection consist of
it consists of them to several things
there is first place the ownership of
tax exempt land held in trust for the
Indians by the United States as trustee
which we call reservations then there is
the right of the Indians to a guarantee
of education health service extension
service Industrial Aid and a number of
other services that we ordinarily enjoy
from our municipalities counties and
States
on the part of the federal government
plus the very important and basic right
deriving from their ancient position as
sovereign tribes to have Home Rule
municipal government by themselves
within the boundaries of their
reservations well mister first why have
the Indians isolated themselves from the
rest of the community what haven't they
assimilated themselves like the rest of
us more recent immigrants I wouldn't say
that they've isolated themselves I would
say that we more recent immigrants
pouring in in large numbers have
isolated them we came upon them when
they were totally unprepared for our way
of life we conquered them rather
brutally and violently we have shown a
very marked racial discrimination
against them we have not prepared them
for our manner of operation when they
leave their reservations and leave their
tribes they usually have extremely
unhappy experiences and above all we
have never offered them a reasonable
education but don't eat the same
educational privileges that the rest of
us do in theory they do in practice they
have not been offered anything
approaching the education offered to an
ordinary American boy until within the
last 20 or 25 years and even now you
have tribes like the Navajos where 50%
of your children of school age cannot
receive any school facilities well if
the federal government gave up its
protection of them why couldn't the
states step in and assume most of the
Indians are in western states the
western states are on the whole not rich
if for the western states had to pick up
the burden of these services to the
Indians
it would be financially impossible for
most them to handle it all the Indians
would do would do would be to drag down
the level of the services estates are
now able to render to their own citizens
which are below the level of the
services to which you're accustomed
let's say here in New York State well a
President Eisenhower I remember said
that the these bills would be another
step in removing the second-class
citizenship status of the Indians
although he did express a desire that
the bills be reconsidered and possibly
amended now what was he referring to
there I don't know what he was referring
to except that he was ill inform the
Indian is not a second-class citizen the
Indians have all the rights and all the
responsibilities that the rest of us
have by that I mean the Indians have the
vote they are liable to military service
and they render military service the
same as all the rest of us and by the
way they do it magnificently they are
free to go anywhere they wish to engage
any business in which they're capable of
engaging or which they wish to attempt
to marry anyone they wish to marry
there is no limitation upon the freedom
of an Indian other than one limitation
that the land that is held for him in
trust like any trust is a trust he can't
break well but the states can actually
seize this land now you say no if this
termination legislation came went
through it goes through then the
protection exists on these lands and its
exemption would terminate well you as
the president of the Association of
American Indian Affairs you said 2/3 a
few months ago I believe that the
Indians are threatened with the greatest
betrayal in the last hundred years now
could you explain just what that
betrayal consists of oh yes I can try to
we have had in the past legislation to
open the way to stripping the property
and the rights as Indians from
a great number of tribes outstandingly
the allotment Act of 1887 but never have
we had in Congress blanket legislation
that the not only the bills to terminate
some 70 the Thetas of some 70,000
Indians you mean an end federal office
give me a person's to be like the
Cherokee Ron and if they white man we're
just running in and take over the
reservation that wouldn't be the case
with it it would be the result and
because in addition to those bills for
the specific Indians there are bills
pending which would in the long run
stripped every living Indian whether he
spoke English was literate illiterate or
not of any vestige of federal protection
when you add all of those up together
you have the most serious attack on the
rights of the Indians that has occurred
literally since the founding of the row
now if the Indians don't want it what's
behind it who does want
well them ah it's you feel a little of
uncertain and trying to say partly a lot
of people are impatient with the failure
we have made and think that perhaps we
could do better if you mille cup these
people loose a lot of people are
deceived by this talk about this class
citizenship and equality not realizing
what rights the Indians now have and
what good citizens they have what
freezes and say now on but on a lot of
Indian land days was oil on a lot of
Indian land that used to be thought to
be desert there is uranium are the
Indians owned a lot of very valuable
timber in Alaska where Indian title has
never been settled and the boundaries
have never been drawn the Indians have a
claim to the best salmon fishing country
and the best timber in the territory
there is a lot of reason why are we very
convenient to liberate these peoples so
that they had no protection and nobody
to defend their rights you mean they
wouldn't be able to sell these
properties if they remained under
federal jurisdiction they couldn't sell
a morally sim except with competent
advice and advice of counsel and under
very strict rules we have an example
that came up in this is up in the in the
state of Utah in a bill to terminate a
small group it came out in that bill in
these hearings on it that their oil
structures under that land that there is
an oil company that has been trying to
lease the land without going through the
statutory controls requiring open
bidding and the best possible terms for
Indians if those Indians are quote
liberated unquote or terminated why then
that oil company can move in on these
people who are very poor and
semi-literate and probably drive a
magnificent bargain mr. Furr does this
mean the end of the Indian Bureau in
Washington of these laws are passed I've
often heard the Indians complain about
the Indian Bureau in Washington and it
would probably end up and the Indian
Bureau along with the Indians
the Indians kicked it what about the
Indian Bureau yes they do
well mr. fudge may I ask you is a final
question of what do you think the
Indians actually want to make them into
full first-class citizens of the United
States education general education and
help to establish themselves in economic
competence to where they can earn their
own livings in the same manner that all
the rest of us do and acceptance the
knowledge and the economic background
and the acceptance to be able to go out
like any other American citizen or stay
on their land like any other American
citizen and be respected and prove
themselves equals do you think that
these laws if they were passed on to the
states would not provide them with these
opportunities they offer no provision
what's - well they merely deprive them
of the best of what
they have fun and so to be a first-class
citizen the Indian must have the
protection of the federal government you
feel must have a protections federal
government and can't kill his first
classes can be innate in himself it does
not derive from legal status it derived
must derive from his own knowledge thank
you very much mr. Lafarge very
interesting to have you here tonight the
opinions expressed on the lawn Jane crow
no scope were those of the speakers the
editorial board for this edition of the
wrong Jean crow no scope was Larry
looser and John Oaks our distinguished
guest was Oliver Defarge president of
the Association on American Indian
Affairs